r dans les mezzanines isla par l'état
madame valérie boyer merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
des images d'une adolescente de 16 ans
tabassé la semaine dernière au coeur de
jeunes milliers par une bande de filles
circulent sur internet
son seul tort avoir porté une jupe au
même moment des étudiants de sciences po
paris organise le hidjab des habitants
leurs camarades à je cite se couvrir les
cheveux d'un voile le temps d'une
journée afin de lutter contre les
discriminations liées au voile quelle
perversité quelle confusion burqa
tchador rabat yannick abidjan peu
importe le nom il constitue un
enfermement dans le sexe une négation de
la personne
un interdit de liberté un interdit
d'égalité un interdit de fraternité
ce n'est pas un problème de gauche ce
n'est pas un problème de droite ce n'est
pas un problème de religion ce n'est pas
qu'un problème d'égalité homme femme
c'est un problème de dignité humaine
aujourd'hui certaines grandes marques de
vêtements intitulée leur collection
islamique pudique ou modeste ce qui
présuppose que les femmes non voilées
sont immodeste impudique ou même encore
pire un pur accepter cette soi-disant
motte s'est conforté le communautarisme
dans notre pays
la bataille du voile est l'expression la
plus visible de la volonté d intégrer de
ce comté de kent leur territoire et de
soumettre les femmes comme les hommes
cette forme de purification
vestimentaire en est le marqueur
aujourd'hui nous voyons dans notre pays
n'ont pas des zones de non droit mais
des zones d'un autre droit où
l'islamisme s'affiche en uniforme et
organise un véritable contrôle social
qui met en danger la cohésion public
à l'heure où les femmes iraniennes
bravent l'interdît en postant d'elle des
photos sans voix les étudiants de
sciences po devraient méditer sur
l'exemple de ces militants de la liberté
monsieur le premier ministre
concrètement pourquoi ce silence
quelles sanctions en vis-à-vis jour de
prendre contre le directeur d'une école
publique censée former l'élite de la
république et qui a couvert cette
dangereuse mascarade
la parole est à madame laurence
rossignol ministre famille de l'enfance
et des droits des femmes
madame la députée valérie boyer vous
évoqué l'agression féroce dont a été
victime une jeune fille la semaine
dernière à gennevilliers
cette affaire sera jugée le 17 mai à
cette étape il est trop tôt pour dire
quelles en sont les motivations et s'il
ya une quelconque connotation religieuse
identifier nous savons simplement que
cette jeune fille a été insulté et
frappé sur des propos et des insultes
concernant également sa tenue
vestimentaire et sa jupe
le gouvernement vous le savez est
particulièrement attaché à la liberté
d'aller et venir des femmes et nous
considérons que c'est un principe qui ne
souffre aucune dérogation
c'est pour cela d'ailleurs que nous
avons conduit l'année dernière une
campagne contre le harcèlement sexuel
dans les transports les femmes ne se
divise pas en deux catégories
d'une part les pudiques qui mériteraient
respect et protection et d'autre part
les impudiques qui mériteraient insultes
et harcèlement moral ou sexuel
je combats madame net
je combats madame la députée toutes les
idéologies tous les intégrismes
religieux et politiques tous les
stéréotypes de genre qui ferait reculer
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et limiterait la liberté des femmes les
femmes sont libres libres de leur corps
libres de leur sexualité libre d'accéder
à l'évêché libres de leur contraception
et la longue marche des femmes vers leur
émancipation vous plaise ou fraude
aucune limite aucune restriction
la république est là la république est
là elle est présente elle est au
rendez-vous pour protéger toutes les
femmes contre les entraves à leur
liberté
merci madame rossignol la parole